за минуле до слова міністрові святі
науки україни чи михайлівна гриневич
шеннон її плани президента США нові
плани прем'єр-міністри США та поза
колеги реформа про святі царі формою
акадо йенном результат не завтра не
одразу не за один рік що по батчат і
продукту новий та система його почту
нам треба пучок від і 10 лиття a latin
анни рублів немає seer і форми надзвичайно
висока а я до чого ми хочемо розуму ти краї
не за лижну
і на водяну конкурентну та економічно
хіба не ну то тут для нас я ключовою
реформа про святі які за своєю суттю
ви перед стиснуті з встигнеш твій проект
уват та його сьогодні система соціальної
середні свити по заду
розвитку сусп листя та процес розуміти
всі люди минулого варити
досвід і процесу зуміє так вже й
освіти анни
там у нас включи вам це ціную і
реформи нової української школи
про той він вогненний випускник людини
кому ж протитенденції ну та бу 20
першому столики
заєць або сну особливі вірші до мислення
критично вони просто запах готові я
курсу дізнайтесь патріот активний гігант
них і статний
захищати свою честь і США але я право
всіх людей та інноватор
іншого торгу six senses актор слова ми
хочемо перейти вид школи до дітей
пхає теоретичними знаннями до школи
deform затишок ключовим словом патент насті 21
століття ціни тільки зайнятися в мене
засовувати їх на практиці практично
мужики з цінності та ставлення то вже
шляхи до інформації так і ешелони та
маніпуляції темпі живому
квн і ніяких ми зараз знаходимося коли
порядку держава агресор шкіряних громадян
їм повинен ліміти критично виходиш з
своєї тіні з але й державної платформи
незабаром платформи восени ватою інформацію
реформа спробуватиме живопис
самонова українська школа з 2018 року
ціну види жита поза стандартом його почту
але у нас вам еша але поза колегією дуже
багато роботи за різьбленим і на прямий комі
оновлення з місця підготовка людських
ресурсів ланки структури та створення
мери джинів чайних закладі змін і
системі управління забезпечення касіус
вигляд і справедливо фінансово не
та нове про sweet не сир та довше ви
знаєте що ми вже за 1 mid крокують шибці
17 рок-опери глянув і
і він вив і програми початку ви і школи
а за 1 проц у нього над програмами та п'ятих
9 класі
а ось з 2017 раків будуть програми для
дітей 1 класу за гали за новими
стандартами колимі у тіні і мур мова і
вправо jenya в цілому реформи нової
української школи
про безумовні рижики cmr еджа
оце вбирався але поза кулером наш з вами
спільна белль подавитися будь ласка
важливо на всю таблицю в сільських серусах
адже на 33 сотки наших дітей в 10
класі у вас десятому 10 клас то сорша
школа коливань і прибирають шо дали знав
буду столітті університету не може вступити
людині професій та технічні вчилася
а щоб розвивати і розвиватися
професій але тримати пишу професію
рік фону 33500 кісти дітей порушується в
школах дим менше 10 вже ні кола і менше
де сад і витрати на дітей ми зібрали в
такі маленькі школи c означає відсудити
en una у кроці 1 в 4 5 6 предметів
she married шанс їх хто з їхніх дітей у цех
33 3 А сотках почем про брат і я кусюм
ріану спеціальний
той-то я констатую шуму і в Україні не
створ або нашим дітям колода доступу
даяки знову святі та tidy тайяки на
прикладному дається в школі сну повна 10
15 дітей десятому платиться з 27500 кен
боже і підлозі ви на наших дітей загнані в
маленьких школи в на я кисні розумом і
навчання
та їх не вшити кваліфікаційний вшитий я
дуже прошу вас голим і звільнений з нашим
гру мадам та й наша так звана позиція
розповіді я прослухані моя школи диму з
мулу до місць і дуже важливо духу що
школа з ну
абоади тени і zara де де де де де де де
на
за для тортів стояла буде для школи та
тому нашим це створи ти таку
інфраструктуру закладин так ми можемо api
2 ст і шкіри нудить і ну в тіу мови про його
нам мало шанси зубу тайяки знову свиту
вісь на ефективно миру жаш киял тут
шкірок може побачите собі і добрий про
аналізу вати пом'ятою так вона вирішу зацін
стояти частка її sweet не шанси шкірні
дитинки янкул зцілитися монолітний
розуміти батька і чемпіони спасибі
ви посадите їх у нормальний автобус і
привезе і в ту нову опорну школу ви
може і їхній парі канати що дитину паяв
для дитинки з'являється шанс на гарного
на іржання упор не школи ми розгадаємо
хлопці школи екзо septic мови але ми
то гріш і з west і тут і більше гитель
не буду нової української школи без
skills я кислим на підлогу на ньому бджоли для
тілу моєму
прошу давайте поділимося цим ресурсом та
ми володіли йому охолонути не сленг і 52
квітучі з десятих мільярдів у мій
новому уроці ви курси але було 42
мільярда за світло не і субвенції
у вас і зрощення дудакова дотація для
обласних районних бюджетів
менше над хаджі та стабілізацією над від
готелю вперше треба на субвенцію для пити
рибки асем судини вимила світло не ми
вимагатимемо і для інклюзивні про світи
я хочу україну поляку в марині анатолій
мені бо взяла на себе потру нації і теми
і з'явилася вперше струму субвенція
ш але поза cool або перед ресурсом є
хочу відразу за законами і зараз
тандемі маємо ресурси для
своїх про хлопця
все в уроку 300 мільйонів гривень
для бідних територіальних громад
для гасимо он і посилав і свою маржу us
with nick закладі
клімату ось 300 мільйонів гривень для всіх
нижчих на обладнання природний ніж
математичний кабінет we лабораторій
200 мільйонів гривень автобуса на засідку
і фінансова і ми попит стріли ЦСП
адже фінансово ній 50 і на 50 до 70 і на
30 споживаючи black обожнювання конкретний
план сьогодні ми так вже змі і він буду
брус починаємо новий проект називається
адже нова ос не сир едовище ми за
кликаємо у вас по так ти сам ці заклади я
тобі буду
наполегливими і ми в результаті від міністерства
святих школа
/ та ташей пілотний проект
місце шуб сам йти нам шкода не програми
ці будуть для всієї України з 2018 року
bull і про пілотів вони вже в 2017 у
цик нових пілотних наполегливих школах 172 см
затятих скілл 511 філе ct що ми зрубали
замінив і почали рік давайте спробуємо
це ваш початково уроку так само шов
втече і шанси дітей та доступу їх не так
я лист з вигляду і я можемо привести
мета приклад шеннон не кулері в нас
шацило низько
бату дітей навчається в силах на
індивідуальному анапчан завжди ти наголос не
школі показовий приклад хлопчик сестру
кивнув годинник індивідуально додому
його привезла бу порнушка краще розсіяти
наш з вами спинний проект у біти на не
могла нормально розбавляти жодного разу мили
причини що води ти нам віру смуглява в
лоб відмовить ну моя година ти не всі добрі
ви волосся так ти напиши дірки той де ніро
ти поза процесами
голосові погляд суки горлового апарату
б ви нас жив барани пам'ятай сім'ї мама ви
зараз на роботі йдіть на низькому і
посилання волосся cool або
ми в центрі Європи 20 польші столики це
наша з вами робота вчать чи agent is
mine ми пари канали саяки пм та світу було
чудове програми не вона вливали на
перенісся в школу текке вчитель
закриваючи за собою двері та even проц
повіти таємну там у я обожнюю шоу ряд і
верховна рада зрубав і дуже правильний
коло і я взяти що їм за це з чим ми та
дня на соціальний статус вчителя
просунувши шиї про поїдання тариф несіть на
дві позиції і так самий шик падав особистих
супротивники у деці
органами з його самоврядування у своїх
кішки виплачують дошкільникам
професіонал технічний з вікі
прокидаються і їх точно 2 тарифні
розряди поспішаючи версія
ти будеш тусувати з усіх у читер
повинен бути
до оціненого підсумку ми маємо право ви
вдень а так вже ви магате
it in a за стригти реформи і я дуже
розруха війна мета позика устричний рук ш
але поза кулером що кілька слив крем
зональні середні світи продажу пиляльний
професіонал технічно там ще з так уже
повного дружина
органів місцевого самого думання задушення
у свиті ми зараз моєму торговець oriental
на steam 10 висимо з половиною тисяч
дітей за минул і рикша та поза колега
вид кр це ваші - або ми у вашій проц і
фондом регіонального розвитку ти ми всі
ми з зусиллям і кішкам і які від рем вони
внаслідок фінансової децентралізації
до датського
26 половиною тисяч місць
душ пильних у дошкільних латах еціо
спочатку вирішимо і вперше столи на читку
дорогу планового закриття проблеми
церкви був шум та були
покрив і 26 половиною тисяч ми будемо
рухати на ступні 3 роки і ми моєму на
рішці реальний шанс підлатати черву
розум у нас слідів концентрації ресурси
доступні професіонал технічного свята
ми ви провали до лірики помел крики bull
і ми нульову руку там ще за 1 по 5
ревінь області та місця обласні центри
подруга кошт і про світло не субвенція на
засмага сміття вдень свиту туди і депо на 2
мільярда гривень е професії
так дзвони рядки з миколи одним закладку
туя викрав для дітей до диких
областей і ми дали вам всі кішки з
державного бюджету, щоб не розлучалася
так що область платити свої кошти і
пастку. факт цим для клинків областей
я 10 мільйонів гривень минуло урок у нас
тварюки не з учасник професіонал
технічний центр
коштувало їх 25 і 50 мільйонів уроку
наша державна інвестиції коли us with
ній реформа в іншому випадку ну а біт на алі
видно і закласти хто буде видувати
україни коли ми з вами будемо консилером
і і як долина jesus Ілля будуть
продовженням
там у давайте спільна розум ми побуду
йому сучасна українська почет за ради
успішно можуть його наших дітей
[оплески]
Степан Степанович бар на минулому
ви могли президента новий план і
прем'єр-міністр хотів би 50 тому такий
коли потрібно вестись від тулі живота Петро
і смак букву обіду електро тріальних
аромат з решти квіти у денді кінні
цій вулиці ще щось менше 1 3 суми
субвенції на територіальні громади
c та проекти та keys перебування на дощ та
не через скарби та й висвітлили за плоди
територіальних громад
україни на прикладі тернопільської
області можна сказати ще минуло muratti
тропічна область відривала 24
тріальний грамот за дикі принцип
нової позиції у ряду був барбарис
лікарю гройсмана 149 та 5 мільйонів гривень
субвенцій на
переможні територіальні громади з
колосальний ресурс такі бук ладан і
а бідні територіальних громад
вона почала 100 c дала можна вести
купити 42 шкільні автобуси тут
біттери конструкції речах 70
об'єкти про кольорові об'єкти України та
виріжте на елементарну програму
рітек не що за дістати яшкін області
ціль і ранки тисячі нових та нових
комп'ютерних
засоби отримала школи область а гаразд
часто ми миємо ситуацію суму роті дикі
ваші плани президент позиції позицій
прем'єр-міністра наша позиція збаражі на
суму роті здув зранку тріальні громади
україни всередині ми кубинці оператора
мільярда гривень вона натиснули
до чого зіпсувати змінилося а збивалося
такі пензлі реальний
стало вже настільки 10 до вердикту було
манул помрете a376 у тому уроці вже став
йому сидячому на та 1 часто помінявся
formulas фінансового підкріплення це та
до 32 сотки
слабка завальна підлога і 75 сотки під
фонд так що будучи 1
мене що оранта ван і фінансово за баста
чині ти з розуму і в три мільярди вид
будете в тому уроці я ґрунтую шегеда не
територіальні громади щонайменше подвоїти
капіталів плоди не в рожевий
інфраструктури
перед реальними грамотами в тому числі зі
сталевий щит і він просто хочу сказати
вже про сьогоднішній dynamics ми сьогодні
чому папок з деками доходимо на одну
особу до нейтральної громади
курили низовиною руку доходи росли 143
гривень на одного особливого мешканця громади
до 720
тантал 400 у чотири рази izrus але доходи
це реальний ресурс, які можливі
ввести виріжте комплекс програм у тому
числа за б спати або його почти і ви
рішення про пробну програму
дівочих відвідавши заклад тягати
, вони міністри та ягід прошу їх що
дозволить і я хотіла незабаром статус на
воду та й ми внесли таку вже таку
пропозиції до
проекту рішення сьогоднішні ради
розтушовується професій на технічне світло
і буду ж часто ставити
областей з передачі майна професіонал
технічні квіти для того, щоб битва
видно зварю ось і
свій морів ж професії на технічних
за кладем який необхідний
регіонального розвитку я дуже прошу
передача ти у ваших бюджетах
штуку порядку вати всю документацію
за майном і по землі вам ми не можемо ось
тут не ось ця q передачу я каштани і
травня оформлена така і документація
яхтинг його на куди оформлена з я
політично воля ми відразу до пологів
серце мій але вигляд видно на реван
областей такий